this movie reminds me why I will never
get in the ocean again ever there is
nothing about the ocean that's good
did you guys find that like when you
make a movie like this you are
second-guessing everything when you step
in the water well shooting in the tank
they prepared us so fully where we would
go in there and not really have to worry
about like how to die like because we
knew how to do that and then we could
focus I'm talking more about the animals
that are in there oh like I'm talking
about sharks and creep oh yeah no I
don't like sharks you know what I
realized though I was talking to one of
the persons I was helping me dive and
they said humans are actually disgusting
like the way you mean you have to worry
if you think look good like the things
that humans put into their body I mean
like we're gross like sharks would not
really want to devour us and that's kind
of like a cool I mean like a smoker like
smokers really have a good chance at not
not dying and the water because like
they they're disgusting people who drink
like all of that like so I think I think
so like a really healthy yeah if you're
I do my and I just turned vegetarian so
that might be kind of bad for me now but
I was just kind of hoping that like yeah
man I hopefully I'm disgusting yeah I
never realized this but it makes actual
sense yeah man we're not saying we like
the food that we eat like I don't think
they would like I don't want all this
process all this process coca-cola
mosquitoes love me yes they do love me
too sweet lips sorry so you have the
script you're thinking about what you're
gonna be doing what's the day that you
are like absolutely excited to film and
what's the day you are scared shitless
all of it no no anything that had to do
underwater I think I remember going into
my first day of shooting in the tank in
London I was terrified because we had
taken a break in between shooting in the
Dominican where we didn't do a lot of
underwater stuff I mean we did an open
dive by choice and then we took the
holidays off and came back January to
film in London
and I had hadn't done it in a little
while and I was like going in a tank and
the set was in there was dark and I was
scared if I quickly had to get over that
yeah the action seems under water can
sometimes get pretty gnarly you know
just in terms of like your incapacity to
breathe properly and and in real life
you know no but then kind of looking
forward to it at the same time of like
wow what is this underwater to Mayan
tomb gonna look like I was really jazzed
to be in that environment yeah there was
a rewrite on a scene a stunt that I had
to do but I was really really like
anticipating it where I had to take the
mask off and underwater and there was a
part where I was looking for my mask and
that was that was intense that was
really I mean we're so well taken care
of but in those moments when when the
water actually starts to fill up and
hear you're completely now underwater
you cannot see there's no acting right
there like no you're just you're in it
and I was nervous about it but it's
exhilarating because that's kind of
every actors dream too - I just have
them make-believe become reality and
like and these kind of kind of films is
really easy to cross that barrier
sometimes with getting a role you are
cast and immediately on set and other
times you have a little bit of time
there so for each of you were you how
quickly were you cast and then standing
on set I think it was pretty fast pretty
quick a month of training you know a few
weeks had two weeks of training I was
gonna say I think I only had two weeks
it was like right before Thanksgiving I
found out I got the job then it was like
alright great gotta start training and I
started my scuba certification and I
remember I had like a week and then I
was in the Dominican right into it right
I have what we call a few fun questions
we're gonna find out if they're fun in
like two minutes
so what TV show would you love to guest
star on Oh Oh Apocalypse Now Apocalypse
Now Apocalypse okay I would love to be
on euphoria or peaky blinders pinky
blind
the Oh a man even though no it's all
date that was one of my favorite show
I like the first season I like the
second see I like all of it man I just
want to learn the movements if anyone
would you I mean I can learn it but I
don't want to learn it in like you are
right yeah do it like the whole camp we
should make a campaign for Brett to
teach you yes she's actually she's right
over the most oh I saw the second Batman
four times in the cinemas I really do
that yeah oddly enough when I was a kid
my dad said one of my favorite movies to
watch was a beautiful mind and I
probably see why yeah I probably seen it
like 12 times along with that's why your
mind is so beautiful exactly good answer
um Leon the professional is a great film
quite a few times yeah yeah can I just
say like I this is not of all time but
I've watched this movie very like too
many times midsummer I'm sure yeah four
times that's not a lot but that's so
much to watch hearing it only came out
not that long ago yeah if you watch it
once like and the fact that I watched
you four times I'm really like it's so
good it's so crazy I'm all Roush saw
that million times what TV show have you
watched all the way through more than
once Breaking Bad Breaking Bad all the
way through more than once more than
once
oh actually no I only did that once I
did peaky blinders I've done that more
than once watch the whole thing what
else my so-called life I've seen it
probably like three times I don't think
there's anything else I would recommend
yeah I watch that way just a kid after
watching like all of Hey Arnold or
something oh yeah I guess like based off
of reruns friends yeah exactly
friends a lot favorite ride at
Disneyland Peter Pan good answer the the
puppet one the one with all the old
machines what was it called it's a small
small world after
just like me I don't like that that's
why I like it so just like kind of like
weird yeah yeah I think it was the is it
the Jurassic that's not you can tell
much I've been there maybe the the
haunted house I'm just making it up my
answers that butchered now often mention
is the elevator one that they took an
art deco hotel it was like the Roosevelt
it's all there but it's gardening
through the galaxy now do you actually
I'll ask you what do you collect rocks
I collect video games shells yeah yeah
and I mean like collects I just have too
many so I guess I can say I collect them
but I've thoroughly played them all - he
collects a lot of things as a kid but I
recently moved so kind of like downsize
things and got rid of stuff I don't need
I don't have anything I collect collect
friends yeah I mean I once brought back
two bags of rocks I'm like a trip to
like New Zealand like this was like
three years ago and then I looked at it
two years later after I did nothing with
it and it was like yeah I'm not gonna
bring back rock anymore
like you find the coins on the shelf you
know they're like really lovely so
they're nice rocks
yeah these rocks these rocks are lovely
rocks but like you know you you you I
think the best thing is to like have
something that you like and display it
as opposed to just collect its rocks or
like yes exactly